ich hab die amazon ein
na ja was macht eine hab ich auch noch
eine frage hast du eine eigene wohnung
oder lebst du noch zu hause und wir
warten das ganze thema auf überhaupt
alleine wohnen nach also wenn irgendwann
zu hause auszieht usw
denn skate richtig ein bisschen das
paradebeispiel ausziehen herumzuschreien
weitergeben du kannst jetzt kommt immer
noch nachbeben eingebaut
ok ich glaube ich kein anfang weil ich
wohl noch gar nicht so lange allein ich
hab das abitur gemacht und ich muss ich
muss ich dann zu hause ausgezogen
studium usw
nach dem abi oder war zuerst noch ein
jahr zu hause direkt nach dem abi also
das ist wahr das ist vor ein paar
monaten erst gewesen alleine oder ganz
allein also das ist wirklich eine
komplette umstellung von zu hause wo ich
sage ich mal die mutter kocht in
anführungszeichen und dann alles selber
selber von selber klo putzen bis selber
entscheiden wann ins bett gehst okay das
ist jetzt so drastisch nicht mal habe
ich früher auch schon gemacht war ja
kein kleiner junge
roger
ja ja genau ein ganz böser junge ein
ganz im ernst es ist egal wie viel man
isst wenn man zu hause aussieht das ist
eine riesen umstellung das sagt jeder
und das kann ich auch einfach nur
bestätigen
aber es ist geil
ganz im ernst ich wohl lieber alleine
inzwischen das ist einfach dass du der
herr im haus ist es so das wünschen wir
einerseits seit jahren alleine zu holen
ja also ich kann es nur empfehlen wohnt
alleine
also bei mir ist so ich wurde natürlich
zurzeit allein ich bin ich bin 16 fährt
bald 17 jahre also ich darf eigentlich
noch davon ausgehen dass staub und ruß
geschwärzt werden oder so alles dann
darf man das aber darf man das allgemein
also wenn du es im jugendamt geklärt
kriegst das schon früher ausziehen jakub
meter musste dann auch so betreutes
wohnen angeboten
aber das andere sache wobei hier stehen
geblieben und zwar ich denke ich werde
halt mein abi machen da bin ich mir
ziemlich sicher liste schaffen und ich
erfahre habe ich fünf sechs männer egal
respekt zollen dass ich nicht
ausgelastet bin hier ist ein spanner und
ölig wird getötet fast aber dass du
nicht ausgerastet bist auch respekt
klasse sache ich bin stolz ich danke dir
danke dir
ich bin auch nur mist hier drin sattel
blut bringen was aber sonst hier fast
wie so kann ist ob ich glaub ich geh mal
wieder meine komische rolle da unten
na ja und zwar und zwar wenn ich meine
ruhe habe werde ich eigentlich glaube
ich erst mal ein bisschen zu hause
bleiben noch ein bisschen so die freie
zeit sage ich mal genießen weil nach dem
abi ist natürlich dann die zeit schon
jetzt wert wäre als wäre er der der
klausurphase ist die zeit natürlich
schon sehr stressig nur danach wenn
man's dann hat das ist ganz klar da muss
man sicherheit auf auf jobsuche kohle
jobsuche begeben beziehungsweise studium
an beginnen und so weiter und ich denke
ich werde erstmal zu hause und danach
mit zwei freunden die die gleiche
richtung studieren wollen wie ich
beziehungsweise in der gleichen stadt
oder gestoßen weil ich dann
wahrscheinlich irgendwie in eine wg
ziehen oder so und dann
studieren dann ja keine ahnung schauen
was noch kommt ich bin erstmal noch
anderthalb jahre in der schule und da
kann sich immer noch was ändern
jänner stecken drei pfeile in mir drin
hallo hallo wenn alles klappt ihr wie
spät es geht gerade irgendetwas 9 uhr
frühstück holen gehen packt den applaus
den kaufmannsladen denn er gibt die
besten die allerbesten egal jetzt jetzt
beantwortet hier willst du später
alleine wohnen oder willst du ganz leise
an dem das ist jedoch nicht verraten
nicht verraten
walter alt gibt sie am besten durch
wörter wie dieses wissen
ok wenn wir das ist offen für die ganzen
leute ihnen kommt dann also mainstream
musik das ist nicht so meins gips da ich
will vielleicht alles aber kein hipster
höchster gefunden ich wurde ich wurde in
beirut geboren aber da war ich schon ein
highlight
einmal mehr ist der coolste hier du
nicht war allein im bett kann oder ob
ich da 1 grad an betten ist wie bei der
außerhalb
was gibt's da haben die partie ich war
kamen konkret
luca bist du am bett nicht das wirklich
will erhöhe man das bringt gar nichts
in der höhle du kannst sofort wieder
reinkommen darum geht es doch
ausdrücklich auch kurz aus ich muss aber
schlafen ich kann noch nicht bauen wenn
du eigentlich qualität den die alleine
lassen ich bin mein haus wegen großes
ungetüm das ist momentan noch sowas von
präsident willst du später alleine leben
ja aber sofort also bei ich mein abi hab
beim jetzt auch vor allem erst mal eine
wohnung suchen besseres internet und
alles 16 größte vorteil bei mir ist es
auch so dass ich mich hier mal hoch
übrigens ich habe den sponsor ihren wir
denke ich da im falle ausbauen werde ich
da und wie hoch kann ich dann mal kurz
geldfragen du hast er 50k internet wie
viel applaus hast du da halb ein
bisschen mehr 27 so wenig ja es ist
immerhin es ist ich habe da noch einen
anderen vertrag von meinem dinger
bekommt der es hat noch mal mehr upload
aber also den habe ich jetzt auch noch
mal geld gekostet fürs wechseln also
eine abzocke aber du kriegst einfach in
deutschland immer weniger richtig wenig
ab laut weil die halt von asymmetrischen
gedeiht umgestaltung erwägen da sollte
ich wirklich jetzt auf anfrage wollte
jetzt nicht fragen wo du wohnst aber auf
jeden fall ob du darauf geachtet hat
sage ich mal extra und in der region zu
ziehen wo diese dieses vdsl oder hast du
vdsl oder keine ahnung ich hab das vdsl
es meiner meinung nach also vdsl habe
ich nicht ich habe eine richtig schnelle
internetverbindung ich könnte bis 150000
gehen wenn ihr von welchem anbieter
kabel oder ist das nur das ist
unitymedia zusammen mit karl w diesen
fusioniert und soja also kabel weil bei
kabels nochmals ein kabel hat immer
total als metrisch wobei
wenn du von der telekom 100000 hast oder
50.000 hast auch schon glaube ich 10.000
da upload was schon aber der ablauf der
upload reicht eigentlich so weit ist
mehr bräuchte ich eigentlich nicht weil
ein video von mir braucht jetzt
irgendwie eine halbe stunde zum
hochladen ist okay und live-streams kann
ich auch meine videos und demenz klein
oder ja ich krieg die sehr klein
gerendert das stimmt schon
etf hier bei uns bonner ich hab dir
bleibt mir durch die höhlen wurden ukm
ich habe mir die ich hab jetzt nicht
mein haus sage ich mal oder meine
wohnung nach der internetverbindung
gesucht sondern ich wollte schon immer
mal eine großstadt ziehen mich dazu so
kleines dorf und hat mich schon immer
angekotzt ja ich würde da irgendwie oder
darüber nach das nicht so sag ich mal
und ich wollte schon immer weg und in
der großstadt hast du also induktiv
gleich gutes internet das ist einfach so
ich weiß nicht ob wir das in der today
show besprochen hatten oder ob das
irgendwas antwort war aber ich würde
immer dadurch schon gesagt dass ich dann
später bei der wohnungssuche schon auch
danach gehen werde was da für ein
internet ist wir haben ich auch
definitiv weil ich hab jetzt 32.000
runtergehen würde ich nie mehr
also ja 16.000 alter bis meine davor
hatte ich 3000 also könnt ihr ungefähr
nachvollziehen wie es für mich ist ja
wenn du videos auf 360 p vorladen lassen
muss dann weißt du was geschlagen hat
ich habe bis vor drei vier jahren hatte
ich ihr sdn das ist 0 0 606 4000 gras da
da kannst du kannst du kein wieder
schauen nicht mal auf 240 ps ja das
war's dann
bei kakao bohnen und ein sportplatz
porno hier viele diamanten lassen
gefunden 66 diamanten danach auf jeden
fall eine der mann spitzhacke ich bin
auch der bob der dann danach ob sie den
fans so lange ich danach bekommen
was würdet ihr installieren
für die bürger ändert es ja ich kann ja
auch wie wir machen die lichtfarbe die
auch ich fahre auch für dich welche ich
bin an tageslicht
wir haben hier ein extra bericht ich nah
dran am pott media house
okay da ja klar welches hause als
nächstes abgebrannt wird man jetzt
abgebrannt oder dort ein haus
das war kein haus ist ein ic waggons
gespart sagen das war kein haus konnte
so nicht aus denn es war so hässlich ich
muss das einfach niederbrennen
außerdem wollte ich da gleich
niederbrennen ich habe gesagt wenn du
mich noch einmal schlägt dann trainings
nieder
übrigens wo ich ja vorhin schon mal kurz
angeschnitten hatte wo ich doch wohin
normalen geschnitten hat bierhoff gipfel
jedenfalls schreibt in die kommentare
ob ihr das jetzt wollte dass dir das so
weiter machen oder ob er das mit den
trollen wollte weil das beschäftigt mich
echt dass selbst alle ankommt von wegen
sondern sein streit anzetteln das finde
ich total unverständlich weil er kam
echt eine menge leute an gemeinten nach
dem motto svp hin etwas kraft macht oder
verhindert was den aller macht und dann
so alles möglich am ende so seiten
aufgeschlagen naja streit ist nicht
irgendein interpretieren dass er noch
immer sofort als so streit wenn man sich
in dem spiel ein bisschen bettelt viele
haben auch geschrieben sollen letzte
battle machen ja das sollte ich mal zum
ausgleich machen aber ich finde es
eigentlich ganz gut die mischung wenn
wir hier auch mal ordentlich sauber über
themen reden und unsere häuser weiter
bauen und dann wenn es einmal zu
meinungsverschiedenheiten kommt dann
nicht sofort rumheulen kinder weiß
sowieso wie noch mal anmerken diese
aufnahme heute muss noch mindestens fünf
stunden gehen weil ich will mein haus
fertig kriegen ja ich schaue ich war
gerade in der höhle
ich schaue jetzt erst mal vorbei wo du
überhaupt nicht gewohnt ich weiß wo dein
haus wohnt ich auch wo denn bei mir ohne
witzig was ist eigentlich so einlädt
battle da wird man sich einfach nur 123
los und wer zuletzt noch lebt hat
gewonnen aber jetzt ich will nur meine
lesung seines hauses laufen sowie was
ich redete ich sagte ich erkläre es hier
gleich ganz ruhig bleibt die frage wo es
kate moss ein haus hinter dem berg für
kenner der kev wieso schreibst du dass
dein haus das so weit hoch geht das wird
meine villa mit garten auf dem dach und
riesen schlafzimmer
und sowieso von anfang an ok neues thema
wir sind schon wieder neues thema welche
welche links auto wollte erklärt ich
jetzt mit ihm habe ich noch das letzte
battle ist kann uns doch mal eure
definition von lap battle in die
kommentare schreiben
aber jetzt erklärt ich erstmal meine und
zwar ist ein experte gibt 1000
verschiedene ausführungen davon aber die
simpelste ist eigentlich man sieht
verschiedene das war ich nicht
es gibt es gibt verschiedene man kann
das verschieden es gibt ja auch viele
unterschiedliche letztes aber meine
definition wäre jetzt einfach man stellt
sich oder das was die meisten gemacht
wird es gibt teams oder einfach zwei
personen aber meisten sind sogar teams
die sich an einem startpunkt einfach
treffen da geht es los dann gibt es in
der great car it also wurde ich nicht
töten darfst von 23 minuten nein leider
nein
als noch doch habe ich auf meinem dach
aus erde ist aber nur mit fleisch